[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Good
morning, everybody.
Gershon Ben Deren is a
fifth degree black belt
in Krav Maga, the fighting
system of the IDF,
and is a professional security
consultant with over 20 years
working as both an
operative and as a trainer.
His book "Krav Maga
Tactical Survival"
presents as many
nonphysical solutions
to violence as physical
ones and describes in detail
how and when to de-escalate
potentially violent situations,
recognizing the warning
signs of an attack,
and how to shut it
down before it happens.
In this talk, you'll learn
the psychology of violence
and how to effectively
communicate
with angry and aggressive
people in order
to resolve conflicts and
disputes before they turn
physical, skills that he
has learned and employed
over his 20-year career dealing
with aggressive and violent
individuals.
Please let me introduce
Gershon Ben Keren.
[APPLAUSE]
GERSHON BEN KEREN: Thank you.
I always try and like
to start these things
by taking something
from real life
and bring it to you
to make it relevant.
So in 2015 July, there
were two women walking back
from a club in South Boston
about 1 AM in the morning.
And they were
jumped by two guys.
One had an imitation pistol.
And it was a basic
mugging scenario.
They screamed.
They shouted.
They were fortunate that there
was an off-duty cop nearby
who came and broke it up.
And the two guys
ran off, escaped,
got into a white car that
was waiting for them, boom.
The women-- or one of them--
wrote a letter to Fox News.
And is really good
to get experiences
from people who've been
in real life situations
and see what they did
right, what they did wrong.
This isn't to blame
anybody, but so
that we can have some
takeaways to see how we can
improve our survival chances.
And one of the lines
that was in the letter
was that she wrote,
"Although we'd both
taken self-defense courses
before, and they were useful,
everything happened so fast
that we didn't have time
to do anything."
And I could take that as
a self-defense instructor
and be insulted by it, and
say, well hang on a minute,
why didn't you get your
self-defense to work.
But I actually agree with them.
And I don't believe
that self-defense
as self-defense works.
And this is something
I've experienced over
20 years personally,
from my own experiences,
talking to other
security personnel,
and watching violence unfold.
Self-defense, or physical
self-defense, as a standalone
simply doesn't work.
If I was to be standing
here talking to you,
and suddenly, somebody
ran out from the curtains,
tackled me from behind,
and took me to the ground,
I would have a lot
of catching up to do.
I'd be a long way
behind the curve.
This person had the initiative.
They're the one that's
putting a plan into action.
However, if I had a
level of awareness to me
that I heard movement behind
me, and I turned to face,
now I stand a better chance
of getting my self-defense
to work.
And that piece, that
awareness piece, the knowledge
and the skills to identify
and predict violence
before it occurs we refer to
as the self-protection piece.
And without that
self-protection piece,
self-defense really falls flat.
And I think
everybody knows that.
Inherently, we kind of know it,
which is why a lot of people
have a lot of doubts about
learning self-defense.
Because they really
don't believe
that it's going to work.
And one of the things we've
tried to do in both books--
and I would say "we," because
it's a collective effort.
I may write it,
but I have a team
of instructors who we
discuss, debate, and work out
the choreography of the
photographs, et cetera.
We try and put
violence into context.
So rather than just
say, here's a technique,
we really talk about solutions.
Because techniques,
on their own, fail.
But as part of a solution,
we can make them work.
So part of what I want to
discuss and present today
is to give you an
understanding of how
certain violent
situations evolve,
get created, how you
can identify them,
and what nonphysical things you
can do to possibly avoid them,
or at the very least, get
your self-defense techniques
to work, or improve
their chances.
And that's that
self-protection piece.
So I know some of you have
scanned through the book.
I know it's a first book.
But you will probably have seen
that we shot the photographs
in the locations where assaults
are likely to take place,
some bars, around ATMs,
restaurants, parking lots, all
of those places where
we can give a context,
and where we can talk about how
a violent situation actually
develops and evolve, and
how you can pick out warning
signs in that situation.
And we do exactly the
same in the second book.
So a large part of
our effectiveness
comes from putting
violence in context,
helping people understand how
violent situations develop
so that they can spot
those warning signs,
hopefully walk away, if
not in certain situations,
de-escalate, resolve
the conflict.
And in other situations, if
they need a physical solution,
at least they've had time to
put some level of preparation
into place to get those physical
techniques to work as part
of the overall solution.
One of the simple
things I always
see lacking in a lot of
self-defense instructionals
when I watch on
YouTube and in videos
is a key piece that seems to get
forgotten all the time, which
is disengagement.
So even after you've
done something,
you've got to disengage.
And often we get blinded by,
we need to learn the technique
and forget that, possibly, using
a technique to escape a hold
or get out of a
situation, we need
to put a disengagement
piece in and go.
Because it's only when we're
out of that situation that
the violent incident
actually ends.
So what I'm going to
talk about a lot today
is de-escalation
and disengagement.
I'm a big believer in
creating decision trees.
Because one of the things
which is really hard for us
to do when we're
under the stress
and duress of a
violent situation
dealing with an
aggressive individual
is actually deciding what to do.
Should we walk away?
Should we talk?
Should we get physical?
So most people
get caught in what
we call a deliberation
loop of trying to decide
what the best solution is.
So what I'm going
to do now is go
through a kind of top-down
decision tree of understanding
violent situations
so that you almost
have a pre-built
set of responses
based on an aggressor's actions
and behaviors towards you.
There's basically
two types of violence
that you're going to face.
We have what we
call premeditated,
and we have spontaneous.
A premeditated
situation would be
one such as a mugging, where an
aggressor goes out, purchases
a weapon, sets themselves up in
a location, looks for victims,
carries out some form
of surveillance on them,
watches how they
act, behave, moves,
or what we call synchronizes
their movement to theirs,
and then sticks a knife to
them and demands a wallet.
It's all planned, yeah?
We have spontaneous
acts of violence.
These would be examples
such as cutting somebody off
in traffic.
And because you've cut
them off in traffic,
they've spontaneously become
aggressive towards you.
Accidentally spilling
a drink over somebody--
that person didn't come to
that scene, that situation,
with the intent of becoming
aggressive and violent,
but your actions and behaviors
have caused them to do so.
And they might not be real.
It could be the perception.
Maybe it wasn't you that
spilled the drink over them.
Maybe it was somebody
else that forced
you to cut them off in traffic.
But the perception is that
your actions and behaviors
have caused them to become
aggressive towards you.
In premeditated situations,
we have the chance
of spotting and identifying
the stages and processes
that a predatory
individual uses.
So for example, if
I'm in a crowded area
and I catch somebody
target glancing--
that's somebody who might move
to a location, glance at me,
move to another
location, glance at me--
this person has
an interest in me.
It might be I see them
scanning, looking around.
So maybe they're
checking for exits
that they can go down after
they commit the crime.
Maybe they're looking for the
presence of law enforcement,
of CCTV cameras.
These are things
that I can spot.
And so I can predict.
Spontaneous situations,
by the very nature,
I can't predict, because
they just happen.
I can be as careful as I want
carrying some drinks back
from a bar, and
somebody knocks into me.
I can't predict that
that was going to happen.
And there's two big differences
between premeditated and
spontaneous situations.
In premeditated situations,
there's an outcome.
If somebody wants to mug you,
they have an outcome in mind.
They want your wallet.
They want your mobile phone.
In a spontaneous
situation, the person
doesn't have an outcome in mind.
The person that
you spill a drink
over doesn't really know what's
going to make that situation
right for them.
The person that you
cut off in traffic
doesn't really know what's
going to make the situation
right for them.
They've just become
aggressive towards you because
of your actions and behaviors.
So when we look at
premeditated situations,
we have a simple choice.
If you're a mugger
who wants my wallet,
I can hand it over to you.
And in probably 99% of
situations, you're going to go.
If you stay, there's obviously
a secondary motive at play.
And I probably need to
enact a physical solution
to deal with it.
So I've got a nice,
simple decision tree.
If you want me, and
you want to move me
from one location to another,
that's a different matter.
Because now you obviously want
to do something to me that you
couldn't do in this location.
So I have a little decision tree
with premeditated situations.
Do you want my resources?
Do you want me?
If you want my resources,
I give them to you.
You go.
If you don't go, I need to
enact a physical solution.
If you want me rather
than my resources,
I need to enact a
physical solution.
Does that makes sense to people?
But the first
question I have to ask
is, is it a premeditated
situation or a spontaneous one.
And obviously, the
person involved
will give me clues to that.
If they stick a wallet--
a knife to me and demand my
wallet, there's an outcome.
It's premeditated.
If I spill a drink
over somebody,
and somebody starts
screaming and shouting at me
without making an actual
demand, then I kind of
know it's a
spontaneous situation.
When we look at the
two books in tandem,
the first book largely deals
with premeditated situations.
So it looks at mugging
situations, abduction
situations.
The second book largely looks
at spontaneous situations,
violence that happens
in social settings.
So that's a kind of
balance of the two books.
And what I want to
talk about today now
is more about those
spontaneous situations
and what you need to do to try
and de-escalate them, resolve
the conflict, and be
able to walk away.
And I'm actually going
to explain the process
for doing that.
So if you're confronted by an
aggressor-- first question,
premeditated or spontaneous?
Premeditated-- I work
down that decision tree.
Spontaneous-- I'm going to
try and help this person
find a nonviolent outcome.
So I'm going to help
them define an outcome.
At the moment, if I
spill a drink over them,
they have nothing
in their head that
says this is what they want
to get out of the situation.
And that's why they're
becoming aggressive.
And if we look at what it takes
for somebody to be aggressive,
we see a couple of things.
The first one-- they
need to feel justified.
They need to feel
justified to be aggressive,
to be angry towards you.
The other thing is they
can't see any alternatives.
So they're justified in acting
aggressively towards you,
and they can't see any
alternatives other than acting
aggressively towards you.
So part of our job in
de-escalating a situation
and resolving the conflict
without it going physical
is to help present
alternatives to that aggressor
so that they can consider
a nonviolent solution.
And often we get confused
between de-escalation
and conflict resolution.
And one has to come
before the other.
If somebody is in a highly
emotional state over having
a drink spilt over them, until
we can get that emotion down,
they won't really be able to see
a resolution to the conflict.
And we won't be able to,
because they're too emotional.
And I'm going to kind of draw a
little picture here, hopefully,
which will explain
how people think
and act when they
become violent.
So you'll have to
excuse me here.
My drawing skills used
to be pretty good,
and they're even worse now.
This is a brain believe,
it or not, yeah?
Thank you.
And I'm going to
explain a theory
that a guy, McClellan, put
forward in the '60s called
triune brain theory.
He was an evolutionary
psychologist.
And he was trying
to explain kind
of how we have come to
have the brain that we do.
His theory, as an
evolutionary theory,
has kind of been
dispelled and debunked.
But conceptually, his model
gives us a good understanding
of how different areas of our
understanding and emotions
control our actions
and behaviors,
especially when angry.
So he put forward the idea
that we have a reasoning brain,
the brain that we're
using now, the brain that
helps us understand ideas,
concepts, principles,
be creative, all of
those things, the one
that, hopefully, we're
using most of the time.
But he also said we have a
mammalian or limbic system
brain.
And at the base, we also
have a reptilian brain.
So what he was basically
putting forward
is, we have this kind of
human reasoning brain,
but we also have this
animalistic type of brain,
which is split into two.
Most of the time, we're
using our reasoning brain.
But as we become more emotional,
we start to switch that off,
and we start moving
to the limbic brain.
And when we're
highly emotional, we
start using that
reptilian brain.
Have you ever told an
angry person to calm down?
Has it ever worked?
No, and I'll explain why.
When somebody uses
their limbic brain--
and it's good to think of the
limbic brain as a dog brain,
yeah?
Dogs are social
creatures, and they
resolve conflict in a number
of ways other than fighting.
Dogs in a pack will rarely
fight, same in a wolf pack.
Because the wolf pack's survival
relies on every one of the dogs
being healthy and able to hunt.
So they have different
ways of resolving conflict
within the pecking order.
And two of the ways they do
it is through posturing--
well, it gets a bit messy--
and submission.
So when dogs have a
conflict in a pack,
there'll be some growling.
There will be some snarling.
They'll raise their hackles.
Their tails will come up.
And then one will normally
go down, roll on its back,
show its throat--
conflict resolved.
When you tell
somebody to calm down,
and they're using
their limbic system
brain because they've
become emotional,
you're posturing to them.
You're telling them what to do.
Calm down-- you're
giving them an order.
And if you've told
somebody to calm down,
you were probably met with
the response, I am calm.
Because that person's
posturing back to you.
And you can say as nicely,
and as pleasantly, you know,
and as pleading as you want.
But that instruction is taken
as an act of posturing, yeah?
Please be quiet, don't shout--
these are all instructions.
They're all acts of posturing,
which are basically just going
to elevate the situation
and escalate it rather
than de-escalate it.
Now, if the person
is highly emotive
and they're working with
the reptilian brain,
they're going to interpret
as either fight or flight.
We all heard of fight
or flight responses.
So if you tell somebody who's
working off that reptilian
brain, yeah--
they've bypassed the
limbic system brain.
They're highly emotional.
They're really angry, and
you tell them to calm down--
that's fighting talk.
So what we have to
do is get the person
back to using their
reasoning brain.
Because if we're dealing with
a reasonable person, well,
we know that reasonable people
aren't going to attack us,
aren't going to become violent.
So when we look at what
de-escalation actually is,
we're trying to move
the person from working
with the reptilian or
limbic system brain
back up to working with
their reasoning brain.
Because if their reasoning
brain is functioned,
they can start to
consider alternatives.
When they're highly emotional,
and the reasoning brain
is switched off, and
they're working primarily
with their limbic system
or reptilian brain,
they're not thinking
about alternatives.
They're working off
emotional justification.
And part of what we
also have to do--
and I'll explain about that--
is take away that
justification so the person
doesn't have a justification
to become violent towards us.
And this is how we
can resolve a conflict
without it going physical, which
really should be our end game.
Sometimes when I'm interviewed,
people will say, well yeah,
I know that's all right
for everybody else.
But you'd do it
differently, wouldn't you?
You'd get physical.
And it's like, no, I wouldn't.
If I can walk away
from a situation,
if I can de-escalate
a situation,
that's the way I'm going.
Three assumptions I make about
anyone I'm dealing with--
they're armed, even if I can't
see a weapon, they're assisted,
there are people in
the environment who
can come to their
aid, and they're able,
they're able to deal with
whatever physical solution I
put in place.
So if I know how to punch,
they know how to block.
So when I look at
that, I want to walk
away from every situation
just like everybody else.
Because I'm no Superman.
I don't want to be in
a situation dealing
with armed multiple assailants
who are competent at what
they're doing.
I want to de-escalate.
I want to walk away as well.
And the easiest
way to get somebody
back to using their
reasoning brain
is to ask questions,
open-ended questions.
And they need to be open-ended.
So a good open-ended question
that I've used a lot in my time
working security--
what can I do to sort this out?
I don't say sorry.
And this is sometimes
where people make
a mistake in de-escalating.
Because remember, I don't
want to give the person
justification.
And if I say sorry,
I'm automatically
justifying the fact
that they have a right
to be angry and
aggressive with me.
So one of the common mistakes
I see in de-escalation
is people apologizing.
Now, when I say, what
can I do sort this out,
there's kind of an
implicit apology
there, but not an explicit one.
So I'm not giving the
person justification
by saying I'm sorry.
But I'm letting them know that
I'm kind of responsible here,
not necessarily
for what happened,
but for what is going to happen.
And often, a lot of
emotional people,
when they're
aggressive, are almost
dying to have a
lifeline thrown to them.
A lot of people
don't want to fight,
but they feel that they have to.
So if somebody can
throw a lifeline to them
and take responsibility
away from them
to deal with the
situation, a lot of people
are happy to take that.
I've seen that a lot working
door and bar security.
So not everybody who
becomes spontaneously
aggressive towards you wants
to move towards violence,
but they kind of feel
compelled that they
have to, especially
if they're in a group
and there's a social setting.
So I'm going to say, what
can I do to sort this out.
And in doing that, I'm letting
the person choose the solution.
So they're having
to think, well, what
would sort this situation out.
Maybe if I spilt
a drink over them,
well, you can buy
me another drink.
OK, the person's now thinking
about nonviolent alternatives
that will resolve
this situation.
And it's a huge difference
between them saying,
well, you can buy me
another drink and me saying,
when I spill a
drink over somebody,
I'll buy you another drink.
Because for them, that will be
taken as an act of posturing.
Because I'm telling
them, this is what's
going to resolve the conflict.
I'll buy you a drink.
That's an end to it.
Whereas if they say to me,
you can buy me another drink,
I'm allowing them
to posture to me.
And violence is
largely ritualistic.
If you look at animals
fight, it's very ritualistic.
Human beings are the same.
So if I allow this person
to posture to me and say,
you can buy me another
drink, and I say, that's OK,
will that sort
the situation out,
I'm playing that
submissive role.
I'm the equivalent of the
dog lying down, rolling
onto its back,
showing its throat.
And one of the things when
we look at social violence
posturing, submission, posturing
will recognize submission,
yeah?
Somebody who's posturing will
recognize submissive behavior.
If they're fight/flight
mode in reptilian brain,
that's probably
not going to work.
So we have to work out, are they
working with the limbic system
brain, are they working
with the reptilian brain.
And people will talk a
lot about warning signs.
How do you identify, how do you
spot when somebody is actually
going to be physically
violent towards you?
And there's so much
research done in this area.
There are so many people
who have worked in security
will tell you all about
the physical cues,
that they'll jut
the chin forward,
they'll bring the arms back,
their color will change.
And these things are all true.
But I challenge anyone
in a state of stress
and duress to pick
up on these things.
They're small, subtle cues.
They exist.
A good example I was
always told when I first
started working door
was, yeah, the blood
will drain away from their
face towards the larger muscle
groups.
That does happen.
But if you're in low
lighting in a club or a bar,
I challenge anyone to spot
that change take place.
And also, you have to
have a point of reference.
Were you looking
at their complexion
before they became angry?
So although, again,
these things happen,
they're not really
good warning signs.
However there are three
really good warning signs
that tell us when somebody
is becoming motivated
towards physical violence.
And this is one of the reasons
why I ask the question, what
can I do to sort this out.
Because I'm going to
judge where the person
is emotionally on their
response to that question.
So there are three
warning signs--
and these are based on my
experiences and others'--
which really tell you when
somebody is getting ready,
as it were, to throw that
punch, make that grab.
First one-- silence.
If you are met with silence when
you say to somebody, what can I
do to sort this out, what
it means is their ability
to verbally process has gone.
And when somebody is moving
towards physical violence,
certain things switch off.
And one of those is the ability
to verbally communicate.
Because if you're
going to fight,
you don't need verbal
communication skills.
So basically, the brain will
clear that to create bandwidth,
yeah, to pick up reaction--
to increase reaction time--
to pick up on physical cues.
So when somebody meets
you with silence,
be pretty sure that
that person is getting
ready to swing that punch.
One big cue when you
look at it physically
is when people turn away.
And they'll turn away, and
then they'll make that strike.
So I'll talk again about
some of the physical setups
when somebody is
going to strike.
Because what you
want to do is look
at all of these in conjunction.
So silence, garbled words--
so when somebody's
speech is garbled,
they mix up the
order of the words.
You drink my spill--
heard that a lot.
And that's kind of like the
one step before silence.
The person is not able
to form sentences.
Their verbal
communication skills
have started to shut down.
They're getting
ready to go physical.
So when I say, what can
I do to sort this out,
and the person is mixing their
words up or meeting with me
silence, I'm pretty sure
de-escalation is not
going to be successful.
And we need to know
when de-escalation won't
be successful as when it will.
The third one is something that
we call repetitive looping.
Repetitive-- when
somebody keeps insisting
their claim against you.
You spilled my drink.
And what the person
is doing is they're
self-justifying to themselves.
Remember that people have to
feel justified to use violence.
So they're repeating
this in their head
over and over again, basically,
to convince themselves
that they're justified
to go physical.
So when I get met with these
three responses to my question,
I know that de-escalation
as de-escalation
is probably not going to work,
that the person's reasoning
brain is so far shut
off that they're not
going to be able to
consider any alternatives.
You might have noticed,
as well, that my--
as I'm talking about this, my--
body language moves and shifts.
Because I want to prepare
myself for that situation
where my de-escalation
is not going to work.
And this is, again, part of what
gets my self-defense to work.
So if I'm standing nose to
nose to somebody with my hands
down as they're screaming
and shouting in my face,
if they want to grab me, punch
me, my chances of actually
defending that are pretty low.
Their action will
beat my reaction.
Remember what we said
about catching up
when you're behind the curve?
So one of the first
things I want to do
is step away and
control range so
that if that person wants to
make a physical assault on me,
they have to move forward.
Because it's much easier
for me to deal with a punch
where the person has to
move forward than somebody
who just has to punch me.
I'm putting my hands up and out,
so I'm defending this space.
And my hands are in the
international language
for "I don't want any trouble."
If I was to stand here
in a fighting stance,
I'm really giving
that person a reason
why they should attack me.
Because if they don't,
I'm going to attack them.
So I'll put my hands out.
If it needs to be a
little bit more forceful,
I can move my hands right out
into the international language
for "stop."
So I'll do all of this, hey,
what can I do to sort this out,
with this passive
motion of my hands.
Notice, though, that my
body is very upright.
So I'm not acting
submissive and scared.
And what I'm
effectively doing here
is acting like the
alpha dog in a pack.
A lot of times, people
think that the alpha dog
gets involved in every
little minor dispute.
The alpha dog's a little bit
beyond that in a wolf pack.
The alpha dog will let the
other dogs play with its bone.
Doesn't care about that.
That doesn't affect its
standing in the pecking order.
If its position is
challenged, oh yeah,
it'll posture and possibly
fight to defend that position.
I'm sending mixed signals here.
My hands are passive, but
my posture is confident.
And what I want to do is just,
from that animalistic signal,
put a little bit of doubt
into the person's head who
I'm dealing with.
Maybe I'm not the alpha.
But if I stand there as the
alpha, giving that impression,
and at the same time saying,
what can I do to sort this out,
again, there's
just enough doubts
circulating in my
aggressor's mind
to wonder who they've actually
picked this fight with.
And maybe it would be
better, because I'm
giving you that option
to posture to me,
to go down that route.
The other thing I
do when I step back
is not just to
control range, it's
to judge the person's
response towards me.
Do they follow me
into that space?
And one of the
things I've done here
is set myself up, from
the legal perspective,
to give myself the
right to defend myself.
So a lot of people, when
they think about an assault,
they think it's got to
involve somebody grabbing you,
somebody hitting you.
That's battery.
Assault is when somebody
gives you reason
to fear for your safety--
so they're shouting,
screaming threats at you--
and puts themselves
in a position
where they can cause you harm.
So even though, here,
when he's nose to nose,
it's assault, if I step
back, I'm also confirming,
from a legal position,
if he follows in,
that it's definitely
a case of assault.
And this gives me the
option, under the law,
to preemptively attack.
So I don't have to wait
for him to throw a punch.
And that isn't necessarily
what I'm going to do.
But I'm in a position,
now, to do it if necessary.
So that's what assault is.
If he moved into space,
pulled his arm back,
that's assault and battery.
So it's good to know
where you stand legally.
Because one of the things that
will happen when you're dealing
with an aggressive
person is you'll
have all these doubts
come into your head.
Is it legal for me to hit him?
What are the police
going to say?
What's his attorney going
to say if it goes to court?
And all these doubts will
cause you to hesitate.
So what I like to do,
just as I'm saying,
what can I do to sort
this out, I'm judging,
from what I say,
what his response is.
Do I get a reasonable response--
you can buy me another drink.
You can pay for dry cleaning.
Do I get silence?
Do I get garbled words?
Do I get repetitive looping?
His responses are
basically determining
what my next move is.
So I've stepped back here.
So let's say he follows me
in, and he starts shouting.
I still have one last chance to
try a nonphysical solution, one
last chance.
It's not a guarantee.
Nothing's a guarantee.
As Clint Eastwood
said in Dirty Harry,
"if you want a guarantee,
buy a toaster."
I can kind of help guide, but
none of this is a guarantee.
So I've got my hands up here.
Often I'll talk with
them, and I'll move them.
So if I have to
work preemptively,
is not spotted as
easily as if it's
movement from a static hand.
So I'll talk here.
And the guy's still in my
face, screaming and shouting.
And what I'm going to do
here is push the hands,
not making contact
fast towards his face,
and shout, back off, and
move a good way back.
There's two fears that
we're born with, yeah?
Most other fears we learn.
If you have a fear of
dogs, a fear of snakes,
you learnt that.
You weren't born with it.
And most times, you're
educated by your parents.
There's a famous
experiment that was
done where there was a monkey
that had basically been
bred domestically in captivity.
It had never seen
a snake before.
And so they introduced,
into its enclosure, a snake.
And the monkey goes over
to it and starts poking it.
They then bring a monkey
that grew up in the wild
and introduce it.
And that monkey starts whooping
and screaming, explaining,
this is dangerous,
this is dangerous.
And this domesticated
monkey steps
back, copies the response.
So it's like a learnt fear.
They then repeated this
with the newly-learnt monkey
being introduced to
another monkey who
hadn't seen a snake before.
And so the chain goes
on, this teaching, yep?
So a lot of the time, we are
actually learning our fears.
But two that we're born with--
fast movement, loud noise.
And they stimulate
our flinch reflex.
And what I'm doing
here when I push
my hands fast towards a person's
face is to get them to flinch.
I'm reinforcing that with a
loud noise and a instruction--
back off!
So what I want to do
is get them to flinch.
And what this can do-- and I'm
going to say can do rather than
will do--
is cause them to undergo
an emotional reset.
So suddenly, they've kind of
had the emotion taken away
from them.
And people, unless
they're psychopaths,
need to have a certain level of
emotion, yeah, to attack you.
You see this in the
"pre-fight rituals"
when people are making threats.
They're building
themselves up when they're
doing their repetitive looping.
They're building
themselves up emotionally.
This is why most altercations--
certainly male on male--
start with a bit
of shoving first.
The person's getting
themselves ready emotionally
to make that large,
physically damaging attack.
So while this guy's going
through all of his rituals--
back off!
And also, I'm moving away.
And if I had more space,
I would demonstrate.
But I move a good distance
away from the person.
So they now also have to make
a conscious choice about,
are they going to continue
on with this assault.
Because now they've got
to get themselves back
into an emotional space where
they're justified, yeah,
and they feel ready.
And they've got to make
a physical movement
across that space to
make their attack.
And to be honest, if I'm doing
that back off, I'm not really
staying to watch
the results, yeah?
I'll get that flinch.
That's creating me
time and distance
to make my movement
away from them.
So when I look at my
de-escalation process, what
I'm trying to do
is get the person
to work back using
their reasoning brain.
Easiest way--
open-ended questions.
Don't tell them what to do.
Don't tell them to calm down.
Don't tell them to
please be quiet, yeah?
Don't tell them
to stop shouting.
It's not going to work.
It's just going to escalate the
situation, because they'll take
it as you posturing to them.
I ask my open-ended
question in the hope
that they will re-engage with
their reasoning brain again,
that they'll be able to
consider alternatives,
and they'll be able
to posture to me.
So they'll be able to tell me,
you can buy me another drink.
Great, will that sort
the situation out?
Yep.
Notice I've taken away
their justification now.
As soon as I agree
to their demand,
they now no longer have
a justifiable reason
to assault me.
I'm also, by asking
them the question,
judging silence, garbled
words, repetitive looping.
Are they receptive
to de-escalation?
If that fails, hands come out,
loud noise, fast movement,
trying to stimulate
the flinch reflex.
Get that emotional
reset button going.
There are some things
you can do, as well, when
your de-escalation process is
possibly not going to plan.
When I used to
work door security,
sometimes people would make
some very unreasonable claims.
So you'd walk over, what
can I do to sort this out,
and somebody would tell me that
I should give them a lifetime
membership to the club.
They should never
have to pay again.
Drinks should always be on
the house, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
And I'm not in a
position to go, yes.
So in that situation, I ask
more open-ended questions.
I'm sorry, I'm not
able to do that.
I don't have the authority.
Is there anything else
you can think of that
would sort this out for you?
Because all I've got to do--
pardon me-- is keep them
thinking of alternatives.
And the more they use
their reasoning brain,
the more they're moving away
from their limbic or reptilian.
Other tricks I can do--
I can sometimes ask
them to slow down.
I used to do work with
collections agencies back
in the UK.
And you'd get people ringing up
on the phone going, dear Mrs.
Jones, you owe us 10,000 pounds.
What?
And the guy would
go off on a rant.
And one of the things that
we found worked very well
was asking the
person to slow down.
Could you please slow down?
I'm having trouble understanding
exactly what you're saying.
Because when people speak very
slowly, it's hard for them
to say in that emotional space.
So there are certain
things that I can do--
and we describe
these in the book--
how I can kind of reinforce
that de-escalation process.
But the big one is opening--
is asking that
open-ended question.
What can I do to sort this out?
Don't apologize.
There's an implicit
apology in that statement.
And you want to move
the situation on, yeah?
Apology is moving back
into the situation.
You need to move it on for
a solution, because violence
is extremely fast-moving.
Do it with your body language.
Appear confident,
but also passive.
Don't appear like
a threat to them.
If I do this, maybe he's
justified to attack me first,
yeah, because he's in
fear for his safety.
And I'm in a position
where I can attack him.
So when we start looking
at violent situations,
when we have our decision
tree, premeditated situations,
you want my resources,
here they are.
Violence avoided.
Maybe if you don't go,
you move off-script,
you're not behaving
like a mugger anymore,
maybe now I need to deal
with you physically.
If you want me,
that's another matter.
I'll deal with you physically.
Spontaneous-- start the
de-escalation process.
When I ask the
question, does a person
respond presenting alternatives?
Great, continue
de-escalation process.
They meet me with
silence, garbled words,
repetitive looping, back off!
Does that work?
Yeah, violence avoided.
When we look at
violence as a whole
and we consider that kind of
understanding of the landscape,
we can see that most
violent situations don't
require a physical solution.
We can de-escalate
most situations.
Most violent situations or
potentially violent situations
that you're going
to face are going
to be spontaneous
acts of violence,
yeah, disputes over
parking spaces.
We live in Boston.
I know we haven't had
bad snow this year.
Last year, there was a guy shot
over a parking space, yeah?
He parked in
somebody's space where
the guy had cleared the snow.
I don't think he just
said, I'll move the car.
I'm sure there were words spoken
how that wasn't his space,
he wasn't legally entitled.
And you know what, the guy
might be totally right.
But he got shot being right.
And most times, when you're
dealing with violence,
you have a choice.
Be effective, or be right.
Better to be effective.
And sometimes that means
putting your ego in check,
not arguing whether
you spilt the drink
or you didn't spill
the drink, yeah?
That might not be
the best way to go.
Just what can I do
to sort this out?
From there, maybe
we can branch out.
Maybe you have to buy a drink.
But if I'm thinking that this
guy is armed, he's assisted,
and he's abled, much better
solution for me to go down.
A guy I do a lot of work with
in South Africa, Gabriel Snyder,
says there's two reasons why
you fight, ego or survival.
And that's a question that you
always have to ask yourself.
If I'm not going to hand
over my wallet to the mugger,
is that an ego or
survival choice?
It's an ego choice.
Survival tells me, hand it over.
And in 99% of occasions,
that person will go.
Only when they stay and it's
now a survival situation
do I need to fight.
And when you fight
for ego, there's
a lot of questions in your head.
Am I legally entitled,
morally entitled to do this?
When you're fighting for
survival, everything's open.
Everything's on the table.
And so it's better to have
your decision tree direct
your physical
solutions down to where
it constitutes a survival
situation rather than one
where it's ego-driven.
And that can be hard.
Because when you're
handing over the wallet--
and I've done this.
I've been mugged--
in your head, you're
kind of wanting to
go, oh man, yeah,
you shouldn't have this, yeah?
I actually now
carry two wallets,
one which has about $20,
small business cards,
and looks quite big, and then
a smaller slim-fitting one.
Only in the worst
case scenarios am
I going to be found out, maybe
where it's multiple muggers who
pat me down.
But in most situations, a
mugger wants that over with,
done with as quick as possible.
Here you go.
So again, I can
put things in place
which kind of satisfy my ego
and make me more likely to act.
But that's your question,
ego or survival.
And when you start putting
those situations down,
survival situations are
actually quite rare.
And this is part of what we
talk about in both of the books,
how to avoid, how to
predict, how to identify, how
to walk away, how to disengage.
And all of our
physical solutions
are put in those contexts,
that you don't have a choice,
that they're about survival.
Does anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: So you've talked
a lot about de-escalation
and nonviolent solutions,
non-physical solutions when
someone is specifically
coming at you.
Could you comment on, I guess,
both the wisdom and techniques,
or variations on
these techniques,
of choosing to intervene in
situations between other people
that you think might
develop into violence?
GERSHON BEN KEREN: So first
I'll talk a little bit
about the pitfalls and
perils of intervening
on other people's behalfs.
I'll give you a personal story.
There's myself and
another doorman.
We'd finished shift.
We were walking
back to our cars.
And we hear bang, bang, bang.
So we look across
the road, and we
see this guy slamming this woman
of a glass front of a shop.
And we started talking, going,
we can't really walk by this.
We're going to
have to intervene.
So this is intervening
in two strangers.
And we go over.
And the guy I was working with
taps the man on the shoulder
and says, excuse me sir--
because it's Britain,
and we're very polite--
and it also kind of is
what the police would say,
excuse me sir, you know.
So the guy turns
around and goes,
ah, thank god you're here.
So this is obvious that he felt
very justified to be engaged
in this act of violence.
When he realized we
weren't the police--
obviously, we didn't
have any real authority--
he started to get
aggressive towards us.
We found out what
the situation was,
that he'd given his
keys to his girlfriend.
He wanted to go home.
They'd obviously had some row.
And she wasn't
handing the keys back.
So I wouldn't say he was
justified to use force.
But obviously, for
him, he felt justified.
So we're gradually sort of
getting to the bottom of this.
And then suddenly, she
starts shouting at us,
saying, leave him
alone, leave him alone.
So now we're dealing
with two people
who are aggressive
towards us, one of whom
we've tried to intervene
on their behalf.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GERSHON BEN KEREN: Exactly.
And things that will have
gone through her head
was, she was probably
thinking what would happen
when this situation ended.
And this guy, her boyfriend,
has been somewhat humiliated,
questioned, and possibly
made to back down.
And obviously, that could
prompt a further act of violence
against her.
So you know, it's
understandable.
It's kind of like a survival
mechanism where, OK,
now I'm on your team.
We showed those guys--
like you said, the common enemy.
So there's always a pitfall
in intervening that you're--
what is a well-meant gesture
by you to solve a situation
might not be well taken on board
by either party in the group.
Once we realized that
they were a team,
that's when we walked away.
So you know, again, it's a
certain level of de-escalation
towards her-- calm down--
by aggression towards us.
So again, there's obviously
the pitfall of intervening.
Let's say, though, it's
a situation where--
and we might all have
been in this situation
where you're out for a
drink with a friend who's
had a few too many.
And he's started
acting a little bit
obnoxious towards other people.
Maybe somebody's
given him reason
in his mind to be a little
bit aggressive towards them.
And now we start to see
the situation build.
And we start to see where
this is possibly going to go.
And we want to save our friend.
So we want to intervene
on their behalf.
Because at the
end of the day, we
know that they're not capable
of de-escalating in their state.
And there's only one
way this is going to go.
Or maybe they don't even
know how to de-escalate.
One of the tricks we used
to do as doormen when
somebody had some form of
friction over the evening--
so let's say, for
whatever reason,
I'd had to explain to somebody
that they couldn't do this,
or they were on a warning
that if this happens again,
they would be kicked
out of the club.
When it came time
to kick them out,
I wouldn't be the person
that would kick them out.
Because we've got that
sort of history together.
Somebody else would, because
it's now a new face for them
to interact with.
They don't have a history
of aggression towards them.
And that's kind of what you
have to do with this person.
So you need to get the
attention away from your friend
and on to you.
And that can sometimes mean
physically moving him away.
Tricks you can do--
make yourself a bit more human.
Introduce yourself.
Hey, I'm Gershon.
I saw what was going on, yeah?
Is there any way we
can sort this out?
So you might have to
put yourself in there,
introduce yourself--
something somebody's
not really expecting
if they're acting aggressively.
And sometimes these kind
of unexpected behaviors,
yeah, the person has to
use their reasoning mind
to work out what's going on.
Again, none of it's foolproof.
So that's kind of
the way I would
look in that situation
of intervening.
Move the attention
away from this guy.
Be the new face
in the situation.
And then run through the
de-escalation process.
What can we do to sort this out?
Get the guy's reasoning
brain working again.
Like I say, asking--
introducing yourself is one way.
It's not expected, in an
aggressive confrontation,
for somebody to go,
hi, I'm Dave, yeah?
And that person now, is like,
why-- why has he introduced?
So you're starting
to get the whys.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GERSHON BEN KEREN: Excellent.
Anybody else got anything?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So over the
last couple of years,
there's been a lot of focus on
the news about confrontations
between police and civilians.
I was wondering if you had any
thoughts about if, you know,
this sort of de-escalation
is insufficient for that
because police maybe can't
always walk away or anything,
you know, along those lines.
GERSHON BEN KEREN:
At the end of day,
if police are telling you
to move back, to move away,
you kind of have to.
And it might be,
in that situation,
that your civil rights are
being compromised, whatever.
You have that choice, to be
right or to be effective.
When somebody in law enforcement
puts on their uniform
and tells you to do
something, they're
doing so from a
position of authority.
They might have
overstepped the mark.
They might not have
But they don't have a way
to back down from that.
Because not in that
situation, but if we
took other situations, if law
enforcement were continually
backing down, their
authority would diminish,
and nobody would
listen to any command
that they gave
when it was needed.
The other thing
to understand is,
when somebody's maybe
standing on that line
with an aggressive crowd
moving towards them,
they're undergoing
stress and duress.
And this is something I
think we sometimes forget
about law enforcement, that when
there's a protester screaming
and shouting in their face,
their adrenaline's going,
you know?
And I'm amazed, often, at how
composed law enforcement can be
in the face of such aggression.
So in terms of in
that situation,
you have to make a
decision, you know?
Do you feel that
your civil rights
are being restricted here?
Is this a battle that you
want to have here and now,
in the moment, with that
person who's enforcing the law,
or their understanding
of the law?
Or is it one that's better
left for another day?
Or is there another way that
you can draw attention to it?
I'm always going
to tell everybody,
when law enforcement tells you
to do something, you do it.
It's simple as that.
Because I don't know--
and this is not--
I'm trying to think
of the best way.
I don't know what day this
guy's had to get him to here.
If he's had to turn up and
deal with the death of a child,
you know, in a real
traffic accident,
he's had a series of other
high-stress incidents,
and now he's here put
on that front line,
he's going to be
in a certain state.
And while I don't want to
do is provoke that state.
So if that guy's
telling me to back away,
I'll be backing away.
I might have to explain to him
if I'm being pushed forward
by the crowd.
Hands come out.
Hey, I'm trying to
comply with your order.
Trying to comply.
I'm getting pushed.
But in terms of the
instruction and the order,
that guy's there to be
obeyed, even if it's wrong.
And I know that's a
very complicated issue
for certain sections
of society who
might feel that they're being
over-policed, might feel
that they're being victimized.
And they might hear this
and go, well, you don't what
it's like to walk in my shoes.
And I'm concerned about getting
in that car, that cruiser,
or getting in the van.
I understand all of that.
But at the end of the
day, my general rule
is going to be, if
law enforcement are
telling me to do something,
I'm going to do it.
And you'll often
see, on news clips,
how those who comply
with police when they're
physically restrained
are treated
versus those that fight back.
And often it's those
that are fighting back
that get treated a
lot more harshly.
Because at the end of
the day, this person
needs to be controlled.
If you comply, yeah,
you're probably not going
to get hurt in the slightest.
And I know there are
situations in terms
of some of the control
positions which
have been inappropriately used.
In Boston, in Massachusetts,
with all the police
forces I know, all I've ever
seen is sensible policing.
I don't know if you
go to another state.
I can't speak for that.
Does not make sense?
I know it's a complicated one.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
GERSHON BEN KEREN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]